hey everyone this is Steve Weintraub
with collider and I am here at the
collider Sundance Studio sponsored by
Saratoga Spring Water I want to give
them a huge shout out because it costs a
lot of money to be here uh with Anton
Corbin
did I say that right pretty good enter
Corbin right I apologize because I asked
you off camera how to pronounce it I'm
an a-hole um I love your work and I uh
I'm so happy that you hear in the studio
for your documentary
um so I have a million questions for you
but I first want to say congrats for
being part of Sundance this year cheers
I'm very happy to be here so your resume
is fantastic you've directed feature
films you've done a doc you've directed
tons of music videos
um if someone has actually never seen
anything that you've done before what is
the first thing you'd like them watching
and why
oh um well obviously I'm also a
photographer yes for 50 years now
um so there's that also You've Done
album covers like this I was more aiming
at like things that they could watch
okay well a music video wise uh there's
um uh probably about 100 videos that I
did a lot of Depeche Mode uh or Nirvana
is quite popular in America I think a
hardship box
um
it's one of my favorites uh
um and then uh movies I guess it started
the first one this is control this is a
film about the singer of Bengal Joy
Division who I knew so it was the only
only way I dare to make a movies because
I I knew a lot about it yeah I love
control
um and I that that movie is fantastic by
the way it's going to be most of the
interview me saying it's fantastic okay
I apologize no no don't uh but I am
curious with your feature films
including the documentary
um how
which one changed the most in the
editing room in ways that you did not
expect
um
yeah good question I guess a documentary
because
um you're not in charge the whole time
you you know I'm in charge of the stuff
I shoot but we had to use so much
archival footage which has to be found
and put in there and
um the editor and the realm is fantastic
he was also the editor for control and
for the American
um so
um you know I knew we were going to get
a good movie out of it so for um for I
haven't mentioned the title because I'm
rude but squaring the circle the story
and you pronounce it hypnosis hypnosis
yeah right
um so I'm curious listen for most people
watching this right now they will not
have seen the movie yet so however you
know what hypnosis is exactly so how can
you how have you been saying to friends
and family what the documentary is about
well usually I keep it broader and say
it's about elderly designers from the
70s which is when album sleeve came you
know became a force and in the 80s of
course we've got CDs so the album
sleeves sort of deteriorated in the art
with it but um it's focused really on
two guys they formed a company called
hypnosis and they were at school with
Pink Floyd and so they started with Pink
Floyd the first album and they did all
the albums for Pink Floyd So most people
know one or two of these albums at least
yeah they're responsible for some of the
most iconic images in rock history and
especially anything that people have
seen in the 70s I mean they they most
likely did it
yeah I mean for me I always like the the
most straightforward
um photography uh so at the heart mother
from Pink Floyd or the Gabriel sleeves
you know the more the more
straightforward Photography in a way but
they're very clever uh before uh we had
all the uh
uh integral things we can do now on on
the computer they did it with a with a
knife and glue and pieces of paper they
made really incredible collages and and
made the impossible possible so I have
to ask you what was it that said oh my
God I want to make this I want to tell
this story
well to be honest I was asked to do it
by Poe who's the surviving member of
hypnosis and uh pose as you see in the
film a very good salesman
um so he saw the concept of me I came to
Amsterdam but I live and um I said I'll
do it because obviously you know I only
photograph because I love music so much
it was the only reason for me to pick up
a camera because I wanted to be closer
to the music and um you know very simple
Beginnings as a fans shooting people on
stage and all that but I became a
portrait photographer in the end
but after bonding the publishing
magazines the next the next and the
highest level that I could think of at
the time was doing record sleeves so I
looked at record sleeves from from
whatever when I late 60s late 60s almost
and that was exactly when hypnosis
started one of the things about the
documentary is you have a PO who's able
to talk but there there's not a lot of
footage from back then in their office
working
um so what was it like for you when you
decided okay I'm going to do this but
this really limited assets to pull from
in the 70s or made you know what I mean
yeah absolutely and I had no idea what I
said yes to in a way you know I jumped
into it and um as you can see in the
film The the stuff at Poe is all my
stuff uh and the interviews with the
Pink Floyd guys at Peter gave all that
stuff came from me and Paul McCartney
but uh all the other stuff we were
you know searching and searching to find
stuff that looked original and of course
storm had passed away so we had to look
at stuff that other TV stations made and
all that stuff and put it together and
do do him justice as well sure the thing
that I found was um for people that know
Pink Floyd they know that there's two
members that are not exactly uh best
friends anymore but you managed to get
both of them in the movie
um so talk a little about getting them
and was there any sort of like was it
difficult and were they cool with both
of them being in the film how'd that go
yeah I mean you know Pink Floyd I guess
everybody knows they have four managers
these days just for every member there's
a manager so there's a bit of
negotiating uh going on but I guess the
love for uh hypnosis overwrote all that
and they wanted to be part of this I
mean they were not at the same time in
the studio but
they were all said yes to it in the end
I mean
it took sometimes a while but hold on
yeah it's interesting because
um I believe it's probably
is it it's probably Roger that's most
like storm in terms of you know very
similar personalities
yeah and I think they were very close
friends and uh but they had a bad
falling out and then speak to each other
for years but before storm died they
made up again fortunately and I think
Roger always had a lot for storm anyway
uh it's just I think two headstrong
characters you know so for people that
don't realize obviously you meant you
touched on there was no computers back
then when they were making their album
covers but the documentary uh talks
about like one time where they went up
on a mountain taking a helicopter with a
statue to get the shot you can't these
days no one would ever do this you know
but can you sort of talk about some of
the crazy things that they did to get
the shot to make the perfect album cover
um well one of the craziest things is
also in the film is a sleeve for 10cc
where they uh saw the idea of having a
sheep on a couch
um in in a beautiful ocean uh and um
they sort of went all the way to Hawaii
not realizing there's no sheep in Hawaii
and there was not there were no couches
either for uh
um uh uh
psychoanalysis or whatever so they had a
couch made and they had one sheep to
find one sheep at the University and
they managed to give it a lot of value
and and shot it and then they used it
this small on an album sleeve
um so that with this crazy stuff of
course but the one you mentioned is with
Paul McCartney and Wings with a statue
on the on the mountain top with a
helicopter
um and then when they came back people
said oh that was great but you could
have done it in a studio with a bunch of
salt
and that's true but it's not not so much
fun of course sure and it's the amount
of money they spent to get the shot and
to make an album cover it's but also the
adventure you know I don't know one of
the reasons I'm still a photographer is
that I like the adventure so I don't
plan so many things it's finding things
on the way so talk a little bit about uh
I would imagine with the dock there must
have been a longer cut did you ever have
a version that was like three hours or
much longer there was a first of us a
bit longer but um I think we from the
outset were quite conscious of it has to
be watchable for people who don't know
much about it and you can't just throw a
three-hour documentary interface sure
what was the if you don't mind um what
was the last thing that you cut out
before picture locking was there like
one story or one thing
um
I think it was a conscious decision at
least to keep the after hypnosis the the
Greenback films that that part of the
videos to to uh only actually sort of
mentioned not really showing the footage
part of it because I didn't like it you
know I didn't like what they were making
um it felt 70s to me and that was in the
80s
um and I wanted to concentrate on the
album sleeves sure is there I mean
listen they've made so many iconic
images obviously Dark Side of the Moon
Pink Floyd is possibly the most famous
as someone who makes album covers
yourself and does so much photography is
there of what's one or two or three of
the album covers that you think are just
so iconic you know like of their work
yeah yeah well uh for me at my heart
mother used to putting a cow on an album
sleeve I think that's an incredible
statement but given you know
970 whatever very early on
um very radical and um uh and that was
Pink Floyd for people to realize yeah
because it doesn't say on the elements
leave either what it is
um I really love Peter Gabriel's the
first album sleeve in the car oh yeah
that's a great cover yeah
um and uh oh difficult deciding but like
best after that but um I guess I Led
Zeppelin albums leave
um House of the Holy is that the one
with the baby like the two the kids yeah
because it's always a great story about
that
um yeah but I I have also an interview
with Peter several in the film who's a
mother more modern designer who worked
at Joy Division and established the
whole Factory records uh aesthetic
because I know he doesn't like hypnosis
so much I I wanted to
have that voice in there too and one of
my favorite albums lives there is a Joy
Division uh an unpleasures this is not
so dissimilar to Dark Side of the Moon
so we're comparing them as well sure I'm
glad you actually put that in the film
to show that it wasn't just them you
know um uh so I am curious though when
you are making a film like this did you
have a date where you said to yourself I
need to be done by is there like what is
it like as a director making a doc in
terms of you know the the you know
because you could spend years or you
could also be like I'm doing this over
six months
yeah well I mean that would have been
very optimistic for me to say that
because we had this pandemic stuff
happening and most of the people we film
are towards 80. so they're all a little
uh scary scared I should say of people
coming to their home or themselves
leaving the home but so it took a while
you know we needed a longer time frame
there
um but it it worked and probably
um was better for it I think to have
more time I don't actually know the
release plan is it for sale at Sundance
does it have a distributor a distributed
America's Utopia and it's being released
I believe first week of June or
something oh so for theatrical sure so
for people that don't uh won't be at
Sundance you will be able to see the
film in June yeah in theaters which is
fantastic because the music is of course
great too oh that's the other thing I
was going to ask you about is that you
got to put in a lot of music and I know
music is expensive to put in a movie so
how the did you have
um uh some blackmail or did people just
to say they want their music to be part
of this I you know I came on my bicycle
here so it's it's you know we pay for it
yeah I think a lot of people wanted
their music in it so I'm sure I wasn't
part of the deal making but I'm sure we
we had favorable deals I was going to
say I mean if you're getting uh all the
you know Pink Floyd in it and uh Led
Zeppelin and these uh artists I would
imagine they want their music to be with
their images
yeah I would imagine that too yeah um so
have as a uh I'm curious what are you is
another feature film In Your Horizon
what are you actually working on now
um I'm working on a film that we shoot I
think in uh October November this year
in mostly in Europe
can you give me any more or are you is
it close to the vest
um well it's a story about Patricia
Highsmith who was the the writer of The
Talented Mr Ripley and a stranger on the
train for Hitchcock and stuff like that
so is it a bio film or uh it's fictional
but yeah that's that's this biographical
elements in there for sure got it uh I
like I'm gonna keep on digging because
they have a title yes you're not going
to share yes I can share it got it uh
it's called Switzerland it's called
Switzerland yeah is it uh do you have a
um if you don't mind me asking who is uh
paying for does it have a distributor
like is it no you're selling it we're
putting a package together oh I like
this
um well first of all I really hope this
comes together which I'm confident it
will
um but I'm trying to think if there's
anything else uh what if actually you're
up you obviously have very good taste
what is the last movie or TV show that
you've really loved that you want to
recommend to people
oh for I don't think I have
seen anything that people not aware
about you know the the benches of
enniscrone but it's great that's the
last film I saw that I really loved I
think
um
yeah what did you see on the plane
yesterday
uh some documentary
about
any action documentary it was a very
memorable documentary
sorry Brian Wilson oh yeah
yeah touching I mean aesthetically it's
not that great but it's touching to to
see him uh and you mentioned at the
beginning
um some of the music videos you've done
if someone has not seen any of the music
videos is there one you want them
starting with or two uh the new one of
the push mode that comes out in February
oh so you've already shot this yeah uh
which for which song
is called the ghost again
my last thing for you
um how much is it you because you've
shot so many music videos how much is it
a collaboration with the band that
you're working with and how much are
they hiring you because they want you to
bring what you do to the music
well mostly the the letter but um my
most unknown video was written by
somebody else in this Heart-Shaped Box
and it's 90 written by Kurt Cobain and
then I've I've changed some things but
he had very strong visual ideas yeah if
you don't mind a follow-up um I
obviously love his work and um uh if
anyone if no one has seen Montage of
heck uh uh uh Brett's film it's
fantastic but what was it like actually
work with working with him and what do
you think might surprise fans of Kurt to
learn
I guess that he was one of the sweetest
guys you could you could imagine you
know I really like her and he asked me
for another video for a penny royalty
this is the next single and I said no I
can't do it because the video of the
years did is so good it worked so well
I'm gonna disappoint you with the next
one because I I don't think we can cook
at the level so he then said well if you
don't do it I will never make another
video again and he never did so in
hindsight I shoot videos on this video
um for I didn't know that story and
thank you for sharing and uh listen uh
for for everyone at Sundance uh
definitely definitely check out the doc
and for anyone who's not here you'll be
able to see it in June I really want to
give you a sincere thank you for coming
in our studio oh my pleasure and a huge
thank you to all of our sponsors and um
thank you so much really sincerely I
appreciate this very much to pay
attention to the work thanks